for years there's been talked at Will
Smith and Jada Pinkett Smith have an
open marriage
well now singer August Alsina has gone
on record saying it's true and that he
was the other man I actually sat down
with Will and had a conversation due to
the transformation from their marriage
to life partnership that they've spoken
only several times we don't even call
ourselves married anymore yeah you know
it's a life partnership he gave me his
blessing and I have literally never been
in love in that kind of a wait 27
year-old R&B singer August Alsina says
his relationship with Jada lasted four
years her reps call his claims
absolutely not true but August story is
putting the spotlight on the Smith's
unconventional marriage I told well
we're gonna be together we're gonna be
under the same roof you might be on one
end of that joke with somebody else
we're gonna be yeah in this joker
together basically like oh he has an
open relationship yes that's not exactly
yet the pact that we have made to one
another is that I will deliver myself to
her happy and she will deliver herself
to me happy we've never been swingers
never been we never been swinging
understood that's a specific lifestyle
that's a really specific slide we never
been swingers so here's what we know
about August and Jada they met about
five years ago he came to see willow and
Jaden perform in 2015 in London and
that's where we met they were
photographed together on the red carpet
at the 2017 BT Awards August was
actually a guest on Jada's read table
talk show the following year he
described how the 48 year old star
helped him overcome an addiction to
percocet what was the moment that you
decided you needed to get clean I don't
know I was on tour or something but you
you caught me and like literally
broke down about oh yeah about it to
feel your emotion and hear you bawling
that was really a reality check for me
and there was a lot of speculation that
August 20 1992 made his claims during an
interview promoting his new album says
he's still shook walking away from me
butchered like I'm shaking right now is
it disappointing that she never
addressed it oh I really can't even I
never even
can get into the thought of that because
I'm only responsible for myself right
[Music]